la vie de prestige.
Et de mon point de vue,
juste à l'extérieur d'une base militaire à Lawton, dans l'Oklahoma,
je ne faisais pas la distinction entre un journaliste et un acteur.
C'était pour moi, la même chose.
C'était soit
« En direct de Berlin »
ou « je m'occuperai d'elle et la courtiserai quand elle viendra. »
(Rires)
C'était très spécial,
c'était sous les feux de la rampe,
et je savais que c'était fait pour moi.
Cependant à un certain point de mon aventure,
la vie est arrivée.
Ah, voilà qui est mieux.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis atteint d'une maladie appelée vitiligo.
Elle s'est déclenchée tôt dans ma carrière.
C'est une maladie auto-immune.
C'est lorsque, sur votre peau, apparaîssent des taches blanches,
mais en fait, elles sont simplement incolores.
et touchent toutes les ethnies,
tous les âges,
tous les genres,
elle n'est pas contagieuse,
elle n'est pas dangereuse,
mais, c'est une bataille psychologique.
C'est dur.
Ma maladie a été diagnostiquée
lorsque je travaillais chez « Eyewitness News » à New York.
J'étais dans la plus grande ville du pays,
sur la plus connue de leurs stations
et sur l'émission d'actualités de 17h00 la mieux notée.
Le médecin m'a fixé droit dans les yeux et m'a annoncé :
« Vous avez le Vitiligo.
C'est une maladie de peau qui provoque la dépigmentation.
Il n'y a pas de traitement, mais il y a un la-la-la-la.»
Le professeur de Charlie Brown.
(Rires)
Il a dit il n'y a pas de traitement. J'entendis : « Ma carrière est finie.»
Mais je ne pouvais simplement pas abandonner.
Je ne pouvais pas laisser tomber,
parce que nous nous étions beaucoup trop investis.
Et par « nous », je parle de Monsieur Moss,
qui m'a envoyé dans un club de diction et de théâtre plutôt qu'en colle,
ou bien ma sœur qui a en partie financé mes études universitaires,
ou ma mère,
qui m'a simplement tout donné.
Je ne voulais pas abandonner.
J'ai donc décidé de simplement me maquiller et continuer d'avancer,
Je devais porter du maquillage de toute façon. C'est le monde de la TV !
Je me maquillais juste un peu plus, et tout allait bien.
Et pendant plusieurs années, cela s'est vraiment bien passé.
Je suis passé d'un journaliste à New York
à présentateur d'une émission matinale à Detroit,
Motor City.
Et à mesure que la maladie s'aggravait,
je devais me maquiller davantage.
C'était facile.
Sauf pour mes mains.
Voyez, cette maladie est progressive et en constante évolution.
Cela signifie qu'elle va et vient.
À un moment donné, pendant environ un an et demi,
mon visage était complètement blanc.
Oui, ça me fait peur aussi.
(Rires)
Oui.
Puis, avec un peu d'aide,
une partie du pigment est revenue,
mais vivre à travers ce processus
était comme les deux faces d'une pièce.
Quand je porte du maquillage au travail
ou quand je le porte dehors, je suis le mec de la télé.
« Hé, comment allez-vous tous ? Super. »
À la maison, sans le maquillage,
je l'enlevais et c'était comme être lépreux.
Les regards me fixent constamment,
les commentaires en douce.
Certains refusaient de me serrer la main.
Certaines personnes se déplaçaient de l'autre côté du trottoir,
de l'autre côté de l'ascenseur.
J'avais l'impression qu'ils passaient de l'autre côté de la vie.
C'était dur,
et ce furent des années difficiles.
Et honnêtement,
il m'arrivait parfois de devoir me calfreuter.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Je reste à la maison jusqu'à avoir l'esprit clair.
Mais ensuite, je remettais mes œillères,
j'y retournais,
faire mon truc,
mais en faisant cela,
j'ai développé ce...
comportement colérique et grincheux.
La colère est facile,
et les gens me laissaient tranquille,
mais ce n'était pas moi.
Ce n'était pas moi.
Je la laissais me transformer en cet homme colérique, grincheux et tacheté.
Ce n'était tout simplement pas moi.
J'ai donc dû changer.
Je savais que je ne pouvais pas changer les autres personnes.
Les gens vont réagir et faire ce qu'ils vont faire.
Mais il y avait aussi une froide et dure réalité.
J'étais celui
qui montrais de la colère, de la tristesse
et m'isolais.
C'était en fait un choix.
Je passais la porte tous les jours
m'attendant à ce que le monde réagisse avec négativité,
donc je leur ai juste donné ce visage méchant en premier.
Si je voulais du changement, le changement devait commencer par moi.
J'ai adopté donc un plan.
En deux parties, pas si profondes que cela.
1 : laisser les gens me fixer,
me regarder, me fixer tant qu'ils voulaient,
et ne pas réagir.
Parce que la vérité, c'est que quand j'ai eu cette maladie,
j'étais tout le temps devant le miroir à regarder chaque nouvel endroit
essayant de comprendre ce qu'il se passait.
J'avais donc besoin de laisser d'autres personnes avoir cette même opportunité
pour obtenir cette compréhension visuelle.
Numéro deux :
je réagirais avec positivité,
et c'était simplement un sourire,
ou, tout au moins,
un visage bon et sans jugement.
Un plan simple.
Mais cela s'avéra plus difficile que je ne le pensais.
Mais avec le temps,
les choses commencèrent à aller mieux.
Comme cette fois où je suis au magasin et que ce mec me regarde fixement,
comme brûlant un trou d'un côté de ma tête.
Je fais du shopping, il me fixe.
Je vais à la caisse, il me fixe.
Je m'en vais, il est dans une autre queue, il me fixe,
Nous allons à la sortie, il me fixe toujours,
donc je vois qu'il me fixe
et finalement je me tourne vers lui et dis : « Salut, quoi de neuf ! »
Et il dit :
(marmonne nerveusement) « Salut ! »
(Rires)
Gênant.
Alors pour soulager la tension, je dis :
« Ce n'est qu'un trouble cutané.
Ce n'est ni contagieux, ni mortel,
ça me fait juste paraître un peu différent. »
Je finis par parler à ce type pendant cinq minutes.
C'était plutôt cool, non ?
Et à la fin de notre conversation, il dit :
« Vous savez, si vous n'aviez pas de vitilargo -
c'est en fait le vitiligo, mais il essayait, donc -
(Rires)
« Si vous n'aviez pas de vitilargo, vous ressembleriez à ce type à la télévision. »
Et j'étais du genre : « Haha, oui, je comprends ça, je comprends ça, oui. »
(Rires)
Les choses allaient donc bien.
J'avais plus de bons échanges que de mauvais,
jusqu'à ce jour.
J'avais du temps avant le travail.
J'aime regarder les enfants jouer au parc.
Ils sont drôles.
Je me suis donc approché, cette fille ne faisait pas attention -
elle a deux ou trois ans -
elle court, elle court directement dans ma jambe et tombe très fort.
Je pensais qu'elle s'était blessée,
alors je tends la main pour essayer d'aider la petite fille
et elle regarde mon vitiligo
et elle crie !
Les enfants sont de la pure honnêteté.
Elle a deux ou trois ans.
Cette petite fille n'essayait pas d'être méchante.
Elle n'avait pas de malice dans son cœur.
Cette petite fille avait peur.
Elle avait juste peur.
Je ne savais que faire.
J'ai reculé d'un pas et suis resté les bras ballants.
Je suis resté à la maison pendant deux semaines et trois jours après ça.
Il m'a fallu une seconde pour me rendre compte du fait
que j'effrayais les petits enfants.
Et c'était une chose dont je ne pouvais pas me débarrasser avec un sourire.
Mais je me suis remis à mon projet
et j'ai mis mes œillères,
recommençant à sortir.
Deux mois plus tard, je suis dans une épicerie, vers l'étagère du bas,
et j'entends une petite voix dire : « Vous avez un bou-bou ? »
Une petite fille de deux ans, de trois ans, même âge,
mais elle ne pleure pas.
Alors je m'agenouille devant elle
et je ne parle pas le deux ans alors je lève les yeux vers la mère
et demande ce qu'elle a dit.
« Elle pense que vous avez un bobo.
- Non, je n'ai pas de bobo, non, pas du tout. »
Et la petite fille dit :
« Duh-duh-hoy ? »
Je me tourne donc vers la maman pour la traduction,
et elle dit :
« Elle pense que vous êtes blessé. »
Et je dis :« Non, chérie, je ne suis pas blessé du tout, je vais bien. »
Et la petite fille tend sa petite main
et touche mon visage.
Elle essaie de frotter le chocolat dans la vanille,
je ne sais pas.
C'était incroyable !
C'était génial.
Parce qu'elle pensait savoir ce que c'était,
elle me donnait tout ce que je voulais :
bonté, compassion.
Et avec le toucher de cette petite main,
elle guérit la douleur d'un adulte.
Yahou !
Guéri.
J'ai longtemps souri après ça.
La positivité est une chose qui vaut la peine de se battre,
et le combat n'est pas avec les autres ;
c'est interne.
Si vous voulez faire des changements positifs dans votre vie,
vous devez être constamment positif.
Mon groupe sanguin est en fait B positif.
(Rires)
Je sais, c'est une blague de père de la télé,
Ma fille déteste ça, mais je m'en fiche !
Soyez positif !
(Rires)
Un garçon de 14 ans il y a des années -
ce gamin avait du vitiligo.
Il me demanda de montrer mon visage à la télévision.
Je n'allais pas le faire,
car je pensais que j'allais perdre mon emploi,
mais le gamin m'a convaincu en disant :
« Si vous montrez aux gens à quoi vous ressemblez et que vous leur expliquez,
peut-être qu'ils me traiteront différemment. »
Boum ! On enlève les œillères.
J'ai fait un reportage télévisé,
obtint une réponse écrasante.
Je ne savais donc pas quoi faire.
Je pris l'attention et la détournai vers le garçon
et d'autres personnes qui ont du vitiligo.
J'ai commencé un groupe de soutien.
Bientôt, nous remarquâmes « VITFriends »
et les groupes de soutien « V-Strong » dans tout le pays.
En 2016, nous nous sommes réunis pour célébrer la Journée Mondiale du Vitiligo.
Le 25 juin dernier,
nous avions plus de 300 personnes,
tout cela pour célébrer notre événement annuel.
C'était incroyable.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Maintenant, je ne vais pas vous mentir
et dire que c'était rapide ou facile
pour moi de trouver un endroit positif avec cette maladie,
mais je l'ai trouvé.
Mais j'ai aussi obtenu beaucoup plus.
Je suis devenu un homme meilleur,
l'homme que j'ai toujours voulu être,
Le genre de gars qui peut se tenir devant une salle pleine d'nconnus,
raconter quelques-unes des histoires les plus difficiles de sa vie,
terminer le tout avec un sourire
et trouvez le bonheur dans le fait que vous venez tous de sourire en retour.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)